it's a pleasure for me to be back to
raising a dialog in Europe everybody
rushes to Davos
but for me being here with you I think
it's much more important last year he
came as a Spanish foreign minister and
this year I have the pleasure to
participate in my new capacity of head
representative of the european union for
foreign and security policy and that is
precisely what i would like to talk
today the common foreign policy and
defence and security policy that 28 well
now 27 European Union member states have
decided to build common doesn't mean
unique a common policy means that each
one can have its own policy and sharing
a common understanding but a common
understanding of foreign policy is
difficult to build because a country
foreign policy is a way to project its
own identity to the outside world and
that's it's a difficulty for the
Europeans puts us in a difficult
situation because we are still a player
in search of identity we still don't
know exactly what kind of role we want
to play let me elaborate a little bit
more about that we Europeans we should
be proud of what we have achieve from
the ashes of the World War two we built
a system that combines political freedom
economic prosperity and social cohesion
one of the best in the world we suppress
borders among US borders that wear the
scars that history had left in the skin
of our continent and we are together in
a union because we agree that we
we night us it's much more important
that what divides us but however I also
have to recognize that today we are
facing a nationalist and populist
comeback that can put into question
these achievements ladies and gentlemen
after three wars between Germany and
France in the short period of 70 years
then same number of years that India
became independent the reunion has
created to prevent us from using the
power the idea of power against each
other the European Union was built on
the basis that not to use power but
today this logic is no longer valid and
instead of curtailing our power we
should use our Union to enhance it our
historical project does not as it often
is being belief or presented is not
aimed at abolishing the sovereignty of
European states in favor of a kind and
supper European state it has an
objective very precise is to enable
European states to do collectively what
we cannot longer do alone that is what
Europe is all about doing together what
we can no longer do each one of us in
our parts it means to share sovereignty
but sometime to have less formal
sovereignty brings you the capacity for
being more autonomous or have more
dreams of renting you know that will be
able to take your own decisions let me
put an example after in 2004 the Spain
sent troops to Iraq
but after the elections and the change
of a government the new Prime Minister
decided to withdraw the Spanish troops
we did it and nothing happened
nothing happened because we had the Udo
as a currency because if we had had our
old currency the peseta these pasetta
would have suffered the evaluations
after the evaluations suffering
speculative attacks in the financial
markets and we should had forgotten
about the idea of withdrawing our troops
so having less formal sovereignty at the
end it brings you more real sovereignty
this teaches us that pulling our
monetary policies gives us more capacity
to have more power more autonomy in the
world trade is one the best examples of
how we sharing a common European policy
where the Commission negotiates on
behalf of all Member States give us much
more power in the world stage
individually masterda pianist states
have relatively little ways in the world
stage but collectively we are one of the
world's largest trading bloc's together
with the States and China I repeat
that's it what Europe is all about
pulling sovereigntist
to regain influence in the world stage
our unity is our strength but we have to
ask ourselves pulling our sovereignty to
do what what do we want to achieve
that's what I was saying at the
beginning we are a player in search of
identity we have to ask this do we want
to be a player or be a playground if you
want to be a player what kind of a
player and this becomes difficult to
answer because Europeans we have
different stories histories more than
stories we have different histories and
had to build a common story
and these different histories have
shaped our different visions of the
world and as a result we don't have a
common strategic culture if let me give
another example I am a Spaniard it was
born after the Second World War and I
live most of my youth under a military
dictatorship
thanks to the Catholic Church and the
United States because both the Vatican
the states were supporting our dictator
General Franco but by the contrary my
polish friends believed that they own
their freedom to the Catholic Church and
the United States it's funny but is true
but if you believe that you have been
living on the military dictatorship
thanks to the same one that other
beliefs that they own their freedom to
the same people it's very difficult to
share the same vision of the world very
difficult almost impossible and under
these circumstances we have to forge a
common understanding of the world
overcoming our history and there comes
the difficulties we have to build story
overcoming our past histories and that's
why by the moment our common foreign
policy is not a unique foreign policy
and it will take quite a long time to
have just think how long did it take to
pass from a common currency the echo to
the unique currency the Europe from the
common but not unique to the unique how
long did it take more than 25 years and
pooling sovereignty around currency it's
much less difficult that pooling
sovereignty about defence of Foreign
Affairs where the core of the identity
of each country is very well reflected
but today we have to do it because we
are living in a new way polar system and
if we don't do anything we will repeat
the same way where we were living after
the world war in a kind of bipolarity
of two big powers confronting each other
today power politics means that
international law is undermined that
there are fewer agreements and more
vidoes that the territorial integrity of
sovereign stage is being violated the
non-proliferation and disarmament
systems are threatened how can we
prevent power politics from becoming the
organizing principle of international
relations the answer is clear through
multilateral rules the multilateral
rules that have been built with
difficulties should not only be
protected but multiplied in order to
guarantee the security of the
International orders in the current
world if we want to be able to take our
destiny in our hands Europeans are
beginning to realize that we have to
learn to talk the language of power
because being a soft power is not enough
our values and our interest reflect what
we are away stori our preferences of a
strategic political economic choices you
don't need to be more assertive to
defend all of them otherwise the law of
the jungle will prevail and we do not
want that might replaces right
multilateralism is on the siege all of
us know it but we must hold tight and
actively promote it let's defend
international law be it in United
Nations Convention of the law of the sea
humanitarian international law or the
rejection of non-proliferation Europeans
to prevent a race towards nuclear
proliferation in the MENA region thanks
to the John comprehensive plan of action
everybody's talking about it those days
thanks to this agreement today Iran is
not a nuclear power and just imagine the
situation
evylyn would be today a nuclear power
those who want to kill this agreement
claiming that they can negotiate a
better one better for whom should be in
mind that it took 12 years to negotiate
it and that this nuclear deal succeeded
in making the world a safer place and in
this context I have to regret once again
the u.s. decision to withdraw you
naturally from the nuclear deal with
Iran today this Thursday is the three
European Member States participated in
DCP away from Germany United Kingdom
having work a few days ago the dispute
resolution mechanism concerned
implementation of Iran's commitment on
the digital however let me underline as
recently as at our meeting of Foreign
Affairs ministers last week that the
European all of us reaffirm the need to
maintain a live distill knowing very
well how difficult would be to build
another one into the world's great
powers then more and more to use the
tools of the everyday life trade for
example in order to convert in a weapon
everything is being converted in a
weapon trade agreements technology
currency devaluations
all of them at the service of the quest
for power they become political tools
they have always been political tools by
but today they are becoming
more weapons on the soft meaning of the
world but really something that you use
in order to enhance your power
technology is the big word that's going
to be decisive on shaping the new global
order it has always been like this
technology ruled the world as the what
steam engine resulted in Europeans
leading the first Industrial Revolution
in the 19th century the country today
that controls Fiji and artificial
intelligence or the Internet of the
things and sets the world digital
standards will lead the world and some
big powers like China and the US have
clearly understood that this is the
reason why they are in a race to be the
Masters of the new waves of technologies
and we Europeans cannot accept the idea
that the world should organize around a
new steno American by polarity which
would come to replace after 30 years of
transition period the Soviet American
bipolarity
that literally divided Europe on this
point I believe that there is a real
political convergence between Europe and
many countries of this region call it in
the Pacific Asia Pacific doesn't matter
everybody knows what I am referred to
many of the countries of this region
including for sure India Japan Australia
Vietnam among others share this feeling
that's one of the reasons why it's so
important that I am here today to talk
about how can we work together how can
europe and India were together for
multilateralism once again let me give
you some examples both Europe and in
have a major interest in guaranteeing
the survival or the world trade
organization which is strongly being
jeopardized today and the blockade of
the settlement dispute mechanism is
extremely worrisome for us for India for
many of the countries in the Southeast
Asia
and for Europe we have made proposals to
break this the slope this deadlock and
knowing the India's a strong attachment
to the WTO I know that we can work
together on this issue in practical and
effective ways a second area in which we
could strength our cooperation is
maritime security for more than 10 years
now
European Navy European operation
Atalanta has worked to counter piracy in
the Horn of Africa and it has been a
huge success bringing down acts of
piracy to just two attacks in 2018 and
one in 2019 coming from almost 200 in
2010 the key feature behind Atlanta's
success is the fact that actions
offshore a couple with actions on shore
of justice reform alternative life hoods
to address the root causes of piracy if
we do not work in an integrated way we
are just treating symptoms but not
facing the illness and operation
Atalanta
was a good example of cooperation among
many countries among them India the
relationship between the neuron must
become more strategic in view of the
importance of the call whatever you want
Asia or in the Pacific region that's why
it is essential that we develop a new
roadmap for our strategic partnership in
the 2002
the five horizon covering cooperation in
areas from security to digital or
climate change negotiations for this
roadmap started just yesterday and I
hope they will be ready to be a probe on
the next summit in the Europe on the
13th of March
among them the defense and
implementation of the Paris climate
agreement is of particular importance
given India's great ambitions in terms
of renewable energy but also of the big
needs that you have to satisfy on energy
supply to your growing population we are
facing a true climate crisis everybody
knows we literally have no time to lose
we have on these days recently stated a
strong commitment for Europe to become
carbon neutral by 2015 what we call the
Green Deal but maybe both and a deal is
a will let's call it a green will and
this will have to be said by the rest of
humankind because we Europeans will
represent only today 9% of the world
emissions of green goss's 9% even if
tomorrow we were able to cancel
absolutely all our emissions the problem
would not be solved because there is
still 91% produced by the rest of the
world so either we are able to engage
all of us in this process sharing
different responsibilities but acting
together our effort would be a good
example of willingness willing of
transformation but not being enough the
example of the conference in Madrid
shows how much more remains to be done
to be done in 2016 Prime Minister Modi
and European leaders agreed on a
European Union India chip
in Energy and Climate partnership and
today we are working together on an
international solar Alliance
headquartered here in India and last
another example of European Union Indian
corporation is Counter Terrorism I had
the pleasure of having a meeting some
hours ago with the responsible of
national securities National Security
Adviser of India and talked about it
last month we organized here in Delhi
and European Union India
counterterrorism workshop on
investigating the EC's networks these
two days worship brought together India
and European experts and focus on
capacity building of the Indian state
police services to deal with the growing
threat emanating from terrorism network
trying to infiltrate here in Southeast
Asia countries all of that is part of a
new system of global governance I
believe it is important to listen all
the voices of countries like India which
will soon become the most populated
country in the world 2022 will be an
important year for India you will
celebrate the 75th anniversary or using
dependency and all at the same time the
presidency of the g20 let's use this
time in the run-up to 2022 to listen to
your views in how should the world could
like on this century and that can be
done together in a world full of
challenges that travel without passports
and know no borders our cooperation to
defense a rule-based multilateral order
rules base multilateral order
is more necessary than ever because no
country is isolated big strong enough to
be apart from these challenges
challenges to our peace our freedom and
our prosperity that is our common
endeavor that's our common purpose
that's our common word together
thank you
[Applause]